[Musique]
enfin les enfants bourse hu bush
mais oui ce soir je vais raconter une
histoire à nicolas patronales une
histoire qu'ils abondent typique dbt
pour les châles europe tu étais tu pues
du tibet
bon froid
[Musique]
j'écarte une raconte une histoire oui
une histoire de la petite philippine et
de son lap ablon d'accord
un instant je me pose
la dite route et bien
je veux dit bibi
je veux le lapin blanc leurs ailes
philippines cave perdu son âme il a
peint alors pour faire plaisir à leurs
petites filles ont des coquines les
parents de philippine partir avec elle à
la campagne à la recherche de tibi dit
j'espère qu'ils vont retrouver ya la
menace ils montèrent tous les trois dans
une grosse voiture qui faisait beaucoup
de bruit en portant leur pique nique en
avant il au papa nous le retrouverons ce
débit qui n'a pas oublié son tambour et
l'anjou
je vois lapin blanc je vois lapin blanc
là bas au bout du champ la voiture
s'arrêta ils le trouvent heures hélas
qu'à gros cailloux blancs
ils allaient repartir très déçu lorsqu
un tout petit ados s'approche à deux
attend moutons à temps et philippine
essayant d'attraper l'agneau qui prient
pas et s'enfuit poursuivi par la petite
fille et par le papa et la maman qui
courait derrière
ils arrivèrent bientôt dans une bergerie
où le petit agneau se réfugie à près de
sa mère brebis et philippine découvrit
beaucoup d'autres moutons
n'est ce pas dans la bergerie non mais
dans les tables à compter de belles
grosses vaches mois blond et des noires
et blanches
[Musique]
des petits veaux
et aussi des chats des chiens
et puis tout une affaire avec des poules
des canards coin coin
il des joies et aussi des cochons des
chevaux des lapins il y
[Musique]
avait beaucoup de lapins mais pas de
l'apa blanc et philippine et est tout
triste
mais heureusement la fermière très
gentille la console a en lui donnant un
gros fromage blanc à la crème et aux
petits oignons que philippines mange à
de très bonnes à putis et alors il l'a
pas vu là elle n'avait pas retrouvé son
ami mais elle avait passé une excellente
journée à la campagne
et voilà les enfants l'histoire est
terminée vous l'avez aimée oui beaucoup
et bien je vous donne le livre merci le
nov ces cas là ça nous en fait 11 toute
une collection la prison valley
cher
[Musique]
ennuis grenat northman nuit
bonne ni les enfants
fait pour
[Musique]
tu peux te bute ma parole mais c'est le
lapin blanc menon patron c'est moi
nounours aux propos je vous ai bien
notre put allons en route gros phares
serre bonnut des enfants embrasser bien
fort vos parents faites votre toilette
n'oubliez pas de vous laver le don est
fait pour
oh
[Musique]
e